je crois que benjamin une relation avec
une spice girls
non c'est vrai j'ai une relation qui se
bagarre pas pas grand chose quand ça
parle pas de toi un bisou à la salle
alors si c'est juste 10 où on en a déjà
fait ensemble nous deux donc j'étais
nous deux on s'est embrassés sur la
bouche en déconnant pas dire oui je te
rappelle plus quand vous étiez tous les
deux mois baros et reed tout cas c'est
quelqu'un qui avait la barbe le bateau
non mais alors qu'est-ce que c'était
plus bosch celle qu'elle ait taleb ou
moins jolie pardon saluer le sens du don
et ça c'est pas non mais c'était très
sympathique
après l'énorme arrêté de marmonner noël
je marmonne pas alors je dit les choses
stone a fait ce qui s'est passé donc
voila c'était à l'époque où j'étais
travaillé chez michel drucker sus de
gabriel avait été invité sur le sur les
bastions comme d'être sympathique et
très très en forme a donc opposé 2
sortira après en boîte et c'est donc on
attendait a suivi ce qu'ils ont avec
michelle williams et le forestier est
lui aussi en appel
ouais mais quoi mais qui laquelle alors
elle c'était je crois que c'était la nbi
wayne rice ont fait la plus belle c'est
facile fille assez facile du tout et
c'était une soirée très sympathique et
on sait que pierre c'est facile parce
qu'ils étaient des cars sont assez
facile aussi une relation avec une des
filles du groupe abba
dans ma catégorie dans laquelle la
nounou